we'd like to take this opportunity to
officially welcome you to today's
session make your ideas heard how to
gain support and increase your
visibility and with us today is
Professor Rita Cella she is a professor
in the department of management science
and engineering here at Stanford and
faculty director of the Stanford
technology Ventures program she's an
expert on technology strategy Innovation
and learning issues in firms including
achieving short-term and long-term
organic growth Rita so happy to have you
here with us today thank you Robin
excited to do this and uh hello
everybody uh thank you for joining us
and welcome to the webinar so today
first I want to thank you for the
opportunity to uh introduce a few ideas
around Innovation we do a lot of
thinking we do a lot of research around
Innovation at Stanford Innovation makes
or breaks great organizations and what
do I mean exactly by Innovation that's
what we're going to be talking about
today so there ideas ideas are plenty in
organizations especially today uh in the
age of chat gbt you can generate a
gazillion infinite number of new ideas
but taking those ideas into reality in
an existing organ ization that's
extremely hard and that's what we are
going to be talking about today so how
do you get buy in for your ideas so the
goal of today uh during the time during
the webinar is to think about uh
Innovation the ideas you might have the
ideas you will have in the future what
needs change in your organization and
how do you get by in for those ideas so
how do you drive creativity throughout
your organization so this is kind of of
um Innovation 2.0 so it's not enough to
have great ideas but you need to get byy
in for those ideas so that's what we're
going to be talking about today and
someone told me you know R is it a
little bit like you know trying to push
for support for your ideas like you know
you hop on a rocket ship to the moon and
then you bring back maybe a million
dollars and yes that it's a little bit
like that um I want you to do this
because I want you to be excellent at
your job so turning Big Ideas into Sexes
it's just not exciting it's also
important it helps your company to stay
competitive you when you innovate your
customers are happy those profits with
flow in innovation ideas get implemented
and your firm will be around for the
long run there's also an unexpected
bonus for you as a person as an IND
individual as a team member as a leader
in the organization when teams share
ideas in the organization and teams feel
that they are truly heard it makes for a
positive work environment brings up
productivity so when you get credit for
your ideas and somebody is actually
listening it matters it makes you
happier makes you more productive at
work so productivity goes up and finally
you know being recognized as somebody
who is taking their ideas through
getting buy in for your ideas getting
them implemented it's important for
today's job market as well so getting by
in for your innovation ideas truly worth
thinking about so I want you to meet
Marian so Marian is on this slide Marian
grew up in
Manhattan she too had an idea a very
technical idea in her case it it was an
idea around phone calls and she wanted
to sell this idea to her
colleagues so when she started working
on her idea and this was way back this
was year
1982 so 40 years
ago nobody in her organization believed
in her she found no support for the idea
that in her mind she knew that this idea
was going to change the world okay so no
support she felt very discouraged then
one day something happened she found one
person one level up in her
organization who after having a
conversation with Marian started
believing in her idea and in her and
that person said Don't listen to the
others just keep going as fast as you
you can and after that conversation
Marian said you know the feeling of
being small Al together that feeling
left and Marian realized that she has
her power was to fight for that idea so
fast forward 40 years
2022 40 years after she started working
on her idea at B Labs Marian was
inducted to inventor's Hall of Fame so
my point here is that just like her you
can create meaningful change in your
organization and discover that after all
world is very very open to change if you
have the right
tools so what are some of the tools I
want to talk about with you
today so
first we'll talk about about getting
your idea out there for people to see so
how do you create visibility for your
idea number two we'll talk about how to
get recognized as the main person behind
the idea so how do you get credit how do
you become the goto person in the
organization and three we'll talk about
we really delve into finding a key
supporter for your journey so how do you
find how do you identify your most
powerful Ally who's going to work with
you to bring your idea to
life just before we talk about those
three
things why do we need to G buying for
ideas in our organization so why do you
need to sell or said differently you
know even if you're not in sales and
marketing why do you need to think about
getting byy in for for your
ideas because you know selling is really
hard getting buy in for your great
innovation ideas that will change your
organization is difficult and why is
that because anything new is often seen
as exactly the opposite to practical so
new ideas are far far away in people's
minds from practical implemental uh
implementable ideas so they are kind of
the opposite ends of a spectrum and this
is because the more Noel the idea the
more uncertainty there exists in
people's minds whether this idea is
practical can it be cost effective can
it be implementable can it be profitable
at the end will it produce the idea and
the results that we want so what this
means is people associate anything new
any new idea that you're going to
propose with
uncertainty and people don't like
uncertainty and they start having these
negative associations with new ideas
because they are seen as very uncertain
so that's the bad news new ideas very
far away very uncertain from something
that could be implemented now the good
news here is that there's much good data
much good research out there uh that
shows that the bias against this
uncertainty and bias against new ideas
goes away when you build more tolerance
in your audience maybe in your idea in
yourself um more tolerance for
uncertainty so much of what the tools of
this course try to do and in this
webinar today is we try to bring uh
together newness and practical and try
to reduce that uncertainty in people's
minds uh about how these ideas could
actually get implemented
so let us get to work here so the first
uh point I want to talk about is um how
to create a visibility uh for your idea
so if you think about this even the best
ideas in the world they really don't get
implemented unless they top of
mind so those ideas that are visible for
people those ideas that are top of mind
they create urgency in the organization
to implement that idea so visible ideas
become top of mind for people and
there's this urgency to implement them
so you need to create visibility okay um
to create visibility better support you
in your idea Journey so consider a
couple of points here so
first you want to ask do other people
actually know
about your
idea so one simple way that people often
forget about and this is actually free
by the by is to ask for
feedback so simple uh free and yet most
of us don't think about this ask for
feedback um so before you start
selling ask who who is out there others
informally that you can ask feedback
from so this is important couple of
reasons
first it's need finding and that's good
so you can improve your idea but even
more importantly when you ask for
feedback that starts to create awareness
around your idea okay so think about
visibility top of Mind urgency to
implement ask for feedback and people
start thinking about this idea
okay so uh the second point to think
about is who should I go for
feedback so this initial feedback when
you have a budding idea you know who are
the right people to go to so generally
you want to think about people who
appreciate in general appreciate
something new so you want to create this
positive bus around your idea so you
want to go to those people who really
value new
things so who has the best sense in your
organization which ideas have potential
you know who appreciates the new things
and and the first thought in my mind in
your mind might be oh okay I go to my
manager I go to my boss my boss is boss
I might go to my senior Mentor but wait
wait
wait turns out that managers are often
pretty bad at seeing the value in new
ideas their first response is often a no
so to get to the bottom of why managers
are so down on new ideas I want to talk
about some um research that was done by
Justin Burke here at Stanford my
colleague he is a former circus uh
performer himself so this study was uh
done with creators and uh managers who
were former creators in a circus so this
is what what he did so he tracked
individuals with similar skills similar
backgrounds working in Circus they were
all creators of new circus
acts and for this experiment he split uh
the creators in two groups one half of
these individuals retained their creator
job so they were thinking about creating
new acts for circus the other half he
placed
them these same people that were very
good creators in a managerial role keep
in mind that these two groups have
exactly the same same level of expertise
and they were creators they've been in
the organization about the same time now
after a few months these both of these
groups hold their roles after a few
months he asked both groups to come back
and come in and judge the potential of
new uh circus acts so basically evaluate
whether they thought a particular new
circus act was worth implementing
someone had pitched a new uh circus act
and the job of these people were to
evaluate whether this was promising or
not okay and so this is basically asking
for feedback right okay so what he found
was striking differences across the two
groups so first let's take the creators
the the creators who were creators and
still were holding their creator jobs
they actually had phenomenal potential
to predict whether something uh will be
a real hit in an actual circus so they
were really good predictors of what new
ideas should be implemented in the
organization now let's look at the
managers so the managers very
interestingly those individuals who had
all the creative background but had held
a managerial job for a few
months they had started very
interestingly undervaluing new ideas the
these managers voted to implement very
conventional very lowrisk performances
so they were kind of turned in
terrible predictors of what might be an
valuable idea okay so bottom line here
do not ask the managers okay some of my
own work here we uh work together with a
team in medical device industry very
very different setting and um very very
similar results managers job is to say
no predict prevent failure all day long
and they turn they tend to undervalue
Noel ideas because their everyday job is
to prevent failure from happening so
don't ask the managers so who should you
turn
to what about fellow team members
they're close by so would they be a
would they be a good potential group to
ask feedback
from
so um probably again a no and and here's
why so your fellow team
members they might again be risk averse
and this is why they might prefer what's
already out there kind of the status
core and often because I'm not invented
here NIH because the basic tendency of
all of us is to resist
anything that you didn't create so if
they didn't create something thing uh
they probably are not going to Value it
as much as you think they should okay so
again they might be the might not be the
best candidate and unless you involve
them in creation of the idea they
probably love things as they are okay so
who who do we turn to for this initial
feedback so the
solution that we often forget uh but you
you should think about is fellow
innovators so ask feedback from others
in your
organization the F fellows likeminded
people they have no horse in the race
yet they have very good taste of for new
things and they're very likely to
provide the best advice and the best
feedback
so if these fellow investors uh fellow
innovators are also respected bu your
ultimate audience all the better so
think about whether your
leaders if that's who you're selling to
they have a specific group of people
they go for advice whose opinions they
really respect so if these leaders go to
the fellow inators this might be the
group where you want to get your initial
feedback from and they will help you
keep the idea on the table that urgency
hopefully recognize the potential help
you create visibility for your idea and
when they have an idea they want to sell
one day maybe they can turn to you for
feedback okay
so asking for feedback fellow innovators
are the go-to people now what can go
wrong so what are some of the mistakes
here that um we often tend to make uh
when we ask for feedback
well
what can go wrong so if you think about
it you
know it's really your idea so your first
reaction my first instinct is to claim
own ownership you know you were the
first one to came up with this idea why
are we talking about getting feedback
why are we talking about getting
somebody else involved in this process
of of selling or even developing the
idea yeah if you're going to get
feedback so isn't it
fair that you get a full credit why
would you ask anybody
else so you might be shooting yourself
in the foot here so the the reason
is several years ago I actually was
working in a volunteer
organization and uh one of the more
senior leaders who was uh in this
organization in the meetings with me you
know was always asking for feedback from
others and and I found it I have to
admit a little bit annoying like this
person I in my mind back in my mind I
was thinking doesn't this person really
have any ideas of their own like always
asking for feedback and you know like
almost okay I have to be there to help
this
person took me quite a while to realize
that yes this person actually had a lot
of ideas but what this person was doing
they were getting byy in for their ideas
and that's the secret of why they were
so senior so many effective sellers um
they perfected this skill over the years
so they invite others to
co-create and this will pay off I I
guarantee you this will pay off in the
long
run so participation powerful tool of
persuation right it's still your idea I
promise but it's just getting better so
just think about this has anybody asked
you for feedback lately so how how did
it make you feel feels flattering right
you feel valued they are asking for your
opinion right you kind of feel special
provides
validation uh that your opinions do
matter so that's exactly how other
people will feel when you go to them and
ask for feedback on your idea so you are
inviting
them to co-create with you to join in
this fun Innovation Journey it's not a
bother for them uh but in fact by asking
feedback you create a connection with
them they feel their expertise is value
that you actually care and as a result
they want to be part of this they
actually want to help you so bottom line
is it's important to realize how we all
typically react to feedback but feedback
is not criticism it's actually a helpful
gift so one example I want to take is
actually um take us to Hollywood so um I
talked to Kim Ela who is a graduate of
our management science and engineering
department and an organizations expert
and she studies script writers in
Hollywood and how they go about selling
a noble
idea and Kim shared this advice from a
seasoned expert in the industry and this
expert noted if you're pitching a new
script so you're pitching a new idea
whatever the executives so these are the
executives on the other side of the
table from you add to your pitch should
be greeted with a great deal of
enthusiasm and if you can Master it or
because once they start investing their
own creative juices you are getting
closer to the money so so point is
feedback is a gift be open to feedback
increase your chances of gaining
traction for your
idea so how will this work informally
for you
um
probably
start getting feedback from your friend
a colleague you see this week some
people show up late to meetings early
two meetings you know they stay longer
uh strike up a conversation so that
would be a good way there are also a
couple of Tricks about getting feedback
so two specific suggestions I have here
first recommendation is about the level
of detail ask for high level big picture
reactions first so why do why do I say
high level because it's very easy to get
defensive when someone attacks the
specifics of your idea and then you know
what's the point of asking for feedback
if you're not going to follow up if you
just defend the original idea right so
so stay at the high level first and the
second ask for two kinds of feedback
positive and negative so our our
teaching team at Stanford we have a
routine um with our students in the
classroom uh what we try to do is to
take a particular class session or maybe
the entire course to the next level so
we give students an index card so on one
side of the card we ask the students
please write down what you liked about
this class you know what resonated with
you and on the other side of the card
what do you wish we had done differently
so we asked for both positive and
negative uh feedbacks several things
happen here so we see that sometimes
students have quite opposite reaction so
it's good to see uh both the the
weaknesses and strengths of the course
so you kind of see the variety what
other reasons for asking both positives
and negatives I like everybody else you
know I get very defensive about feedback
so when I'm about to dismiss something
you know when someone doesn't like what
I'm doing I flip that card and I see the
positive side of things you know which
then helps me tackle the negative and
what's more through this feedback
process with the audience the students
in this case we debrief with them we
drive home the point that this is
co-creation this is not a one-way Street
we are all in this together we co
creating our learning process in this
class so next time when you ask for
feedback ask for negatives but don't
forget to add the positives the
strengths what is it that other people
like about your
idea and you'll be surprised how how
well this actually
works
okay uh
so oh one final comment about feedback I
wanted to make always follow up so tell
people how the idea worked thank them
for their feedback even if it's some
small changes that you made in your idea
it's worth mentioning uh they know that
their feedback was not wasted their time
was not wasted it reminds them of the
idea it recreates visibility in their
minds for you and your idea so lower
your natural guard and make the most of
feedback and create
visibility so next I want to talk about
how you you want to uh build expertise
around your
idea so one way to create
visibility is to consider how you can
build up your own reputation so you
stand out as the expert in that
particular area in your organization so
how do you do this you can be very very
proactive about this step so volunteer
for a task force that's made may be
relevant to your idea you know share
relevant news there is a colleague of
mine who is Works in a competition
policy uh area he started um sharing
linked on LinkedIn news about
competition policy you know putting a
little bit of an academic spin all of a
sudden he becomes a go-to person in that
topic so there are different little
tricks you you can uh use here maybe on
slack you you post things that are
relevant your area of expertise of
course first you have to build up your
expertise in the area so if others know
uh what you've ached you perceive you as
the expert they will be more open to
listening to your ideas so that's the
idea give you more leverage more
visibility for your
idea again okay what can go wrong so now
you're getting this feedback you're
becoming the expert um other people come
to you they have lots of ideas
there is such thing as as listening too
much so trying to please everyone so
feedback is good but when does feedback
become too much of a good thing so
Tipping Point is when you overreact you
you start pivoting too much you're too
swayed by feedback and and you lose
sight of your original idea I was
talking to a manager in this case this
was a sea level manager uh in and this
manager very successful one uh in in his
role in their role um when when I asked
you know what's behind your success this
person said you know I never I never
reil I never tell others about my plan B
they only hear about my plan a and and
and this person said you know sometimes
I'm actually criticized for that but I
only did visibly promote plan a and why
is
this similarly you might be wondering
you know because people are giving me
feedback I'm getting all of these good
ideas and they might be taking uh me to
another place you know maybe I should
have a couple of different ideas in my
back pocket just in case you know the
main demand doesn't work or maybe this
other one might please people
better probably not a good idea so if
you want to be successful at moving your
idea through the
organization pick one solid idea not
several halfway ideas you want to give
an impression that you're serious about
your ideas you're going to take this
main idea through you are the master of
it and you're going to be selling it
through you're going to seeing it
through so I want to take you again back
to Hollywood and look at Kim's quest to
understand how script writers work the
system so again this is uh what um Kim
was sharing with me this is one of again
one of her interviews from a uh with a
writer producer in Hollywood so you
should never never pitch more than one
maybe two but really one idea at a time
never never never what you're selling is
your
passion there's not a buyer in the world
you can convince that you have the same
p
for five different
projects
Okay the third point and the final Point
uh in our conversation today I wanted to
bring up uh
is step three in creating visibility for
your idea so what else can you
do so you can identify side kicks you
can identify supporters for your idea so
the the idea here my idea here my
suggestion uh for you here is that that
your supporters your Sidekicks maybe
your co-workers in the organization they
can become powerful supporters and
advocates for your idea so think start
thinking about who these Sidekicks who
these allies could be and practical
advice is to think about you know who is
Raising similar types of issues in all
hands meetings you know on
slack and they can really become
powerful Sidekicks and supporters and
why does this
matter why do I have 57% there because
if another person talks you or your idea
up it's
57% more likely to be accepted by
managers than if you do the talking
yourself on the behalf of your own idea
so basically managers are 57% more like
ly to be positively inclined and
influenced by your idea if somebody else
is saying great things about your idea
so identifying these sidekick supporters
super important it's effective selling
your Sidekicks and Al also can be very
helpful uh in testing in bing your idea
so again there are multiple things they
can do for you so the point is here
again although it's all your idea it's
your baby I know but you know selling
solo is very very difficult so uh think
about who else can be in your
team so where do you couple of things
about the best Sidekicks and here I want
to go back to a recent project I did
with a couple of my colleagues uh around
video game developers okay uh and uh
these video game developers they were
picking Sidekicks in their case it was
picking video game
Publishers and uh I wanted to share this
because the video game developers were
really Savvy about their choices of
which Publishers they wanted to get as
their Sidekicks so couple of key
takeaways for you here so first make a
list of what you are good at and then
based on that list what do you need from
others so very simple but effective so
point is to inventory your own expertise
number
two make sure you know and think about
what your Sidekick has to offer will
they most importantly have the time will
they have the resources to help you will
you have to share your Sidekicks
attention with other peers who are
perhaps also seeking for their attention
this is big fish big pond right and then
number three there are partnering terod
offs you know if you're an in
experienced um in your organization you
know don't hesitate to partner with
smaller Sidekicks they might have more
time they might be just starting out as
Sidekicks and they will devote time for
your development they can afford the
perhaps the personalized attention you
need they might help really develop your
idea and in turn if you're more
experienced you know don't hesitate to
seek out sort of bigger puns bigger more
experienced sidekicks
okay
so let's look at the final mistake so
again uh what can go
wrong
so often when you get excited about your
idea and and you you perfect it you hone
it and it becomes you have the perfect
story around
it we tend to forget that who you
actually are as a person the carrier of
the message that also matters a great
deal you're not only selling the idea
you are selling actually yourself so
what does this mean so how do you bring
your whole self to the process of
getting by in so first bring your
expertise to the meeting so it's all
about credibility remind them how this
idea links to what you learned through a
previous project what you learned from a
customer you know what you were trained
in maybe you know you have an
engineering background or maybe you did
Marketing in your previous job or maybe
uh you are super good at coding so
something that's relevant to uh your
idea selling maybe you organized events
in your previous job so the point is if
you look the part you really bring out
you tell them your expertise uh you're
perceived as an expert you will have the
ability to influence behavior influence
decisions so build up that credibility
to se be seen as an
expert and my hunch is that this may be
actually less challenging than you think
if you have an idea in mind that you
want to get implemented in your
organization we all have a natural
tendency to think about and promote
ideas that are close to what we care
about what we already know about so we
often want to speak up about issues that
relate to our expertise in what we do
every day what we actually know about so
this might be easier this building
expertise this uh really seeing as an
expert might be much easier than you
think so my hunch is your idea might be
something that you already know you you
care a great deal about probably more
than anybody else in your organization
so so simply put you are the author the
already you are the expert and that's
just something that you need to
highlight
and what expertise is relevant so you
are experts in your jobs you have life
educational work
experiences think about what expertise
you want to highlight here you know it's
like casting for a play so if you've
been part of a play maybe part of a
community play you heard casting
directors explain their choices this is
the same concept so you need to make the
casting choices you need to highlight
areas of your expertise that matter here
so this is kind of a person role or a
person uh role and pit fit you know you
need to be credible for your audience so
when that actor in that Community play
walks on stage the audience needs to
believe in them so you can hire a
5-year-old who is hilarious in SpongeBob
and then think the same actor can play a
lead Road in uh Percy Jackson which is
you know kind of teenager play so you
need a teenager to make the sell in
Percy Jackson so the same thing
happening here final words of advice
from Hollywood here and from from Kim
you're rarely selling the idea you're
selling you you are selling your
commitment and your point of view so
best best of luck promoting your ideas
and getting traction for your ideas and
I'm um now turning it over back to
Robin hi Rita I'm here that was
wonderful um I really loved everything
that you had to share there we are
getting tons of questions in this is so
exciting I saw so many emojis I saw so
many hearts come up I saw so many thumbs
up so let's dive into some of these
questions look there's two more Hearts
right there okay a right right everyone
thanks so much for being here we really
love the interaction between everyone
who shows up for these so thank you so
much Rita thanks so much it's it's been
great so let's dive into some questions
here Rita Natalie wants to know do you
have any advice for how I can have my
ideas heard beyond my boss I feel like a
small Cog in a huge organization and
it's hard to be
hurt oh that's a super good question
thank you Natalie so one of the things
uh we didn't have time for
today but think
about you know what is every what what
are everybody's goals in the
organization there might somebody there
might be somebody else in another team
maybe another director in a different
team than yours whose job is to get
things around your idea done so
basically think about who is excited
whose job is to do something around the
goals of your idea and align your idea
with with one of their goals so it
doesn't need to be your own team's
responsibility and it might be an idea
that's not super relevant to your boss
but it might be relevant to somebody
else in the organization and you just
need to find that person who there's
again the the fit between the idea and
the person who needs it
yeah I think that's I think that's a a
great thing for me I work a lot cross
functionally and so I get to work with
other team members who I know are
excited about specific topics so going
outside your manager and going over to
someone else who you know is excited
about something and and getting them on
board for it and this is in line this
question from Natalie is in line from
something I saw that just came in from
Carl Carl said I've tried to brief my
manager before meeting so that he has a
holistic understanding of the idea of
The Proposal so and he he said I
subliminally try to transfer ownership
of my ideas to my manager so that I can
get buyin from the team but it has
failed every single time any
recommendations Rita you and I have
talked about this and you said something
that I um I think this is in the course
too you said something when you're
trying to appeal to your manager think
about what their goals are and what
their what leadership is asking from
your manager then also sometimes you can
bring in a personal element Rita do you
remember you said what if you have a
boss who's really interested in baseball
and you start talking to them and you
say hey I think this idea is a home run
how can we how can we get take this idea
to the next level I really love those
those little kinds of things that you
could do it's one of the things is like
you just said it's the vocab it's really
the vocabulary you know use the terms uh
you are it's it's the liking principle
what is it that you have in common how
can you talk in terms that uh your boss
or your boss's boss understands the
other TI well I I actually did this
myself I I will reveal this um so um in
organ in a previous
organization um we used to have all
hands and they would sometimes give out
handouts uh and uh I would pay attention
when somebody was talking about our
teams and our organizations goals for
the next year or next five years and I
actually take that handout and I st it
on my office wall and there I have the
goals I have what's important uh not
only for me but what I think what I I
know is important for my managers one
level up couple of levels up and I have
the language
right absolutely I think it's all about
language you know that that old um that
old game called boulder dash and you're
supposed to you get a you get a word and
you're supposed to like make up the
definition you might not even know what
the word is but you're supposed to make
up the definition think about when you
look up a definition in the dictionary
it says similar to and you just make it
up it's all about the language I totally
agree with you to in order to get
something to move forward but but but
Robin wait one thing is you have to you
have to get to know others in your
organization you don't know what their
language is what is it that you and your
idea um and you your expertise has in
common with somebody else so so to get
to that same wavelength and the sort of
the similar language and terms you
really need to First figure out what do
they care about what's their passion how
does it align with your passion I agree
I agree because if if if it doesn't
align with your passion and there's not
that overlap then you're probably not
going to be very very passionate about
moving it forward so it's about the
overlap I love
that okay next question Laura wants to
know how do you know if an idea is worth
fighting for and
championing O that's a good one thank
you thank you Laura
um something something that I think
about here is you know think about how
the sidekicks how the Allies that we
talked about how do they come
in so so you probably have somebody who
can become your Sidekick we talked about
you know how to identify who has time
who might actually want to be your
sidekick present your idea to them and
see you know what is gaining tracking
where where you know hear them out you
gain valuable feedback and uh you can
validate you can help fine-tune your
idea so that that that's sort of how I
think about with idea is worth fighting
for know I agree yeah and if you're if
you're you know if you're if they're
super excited or if there's no
excitement at all that's kind of a good
pulse yeah I agree and and it doesn't
mean necessarily that you abandon your
idea maybe it's about a pivot but it has
to be a pivot that's well informed and
something that you're still excited
about that you didn't change your whole
idea just because of a piece of feedback
from your allies so I think the allies
and Sidekicks are valuable on so many
levels and you've said that to me like
repeat ly so I really I really
appreciate thinking about not just your
idea in your own little Silo but who can
you bring in and what can they provide
you and I think this is a good example
so Laura thank you so much for your
question
okay let's
see James wants to know this all sounds
great but if I want to begin tomorrow
establishing myself as an expert what's
the top thing I should do of course this
is very subjective there are always
different top things that you can do but
Rita what would you tell
James establishing myself as an expert
so I'm I
know James right James I know James has
a lot of expertise you
probably have many things you already
know so I'm not going to say build your
expertise because you already have it
but it's just letting other S
no just talking to others you know we we
we talked about a few ways to create you
know digital visibility or you know show
up early strike up a conversation with a
colleague about what is important to you
I'm I'm an introvert so I sometimes
script if I know if I know I'm going to
a meeting or to a dinner with a bunch of
people I kind of script what I want to
talk if I strike a I mean I'm I'm really
I'm really extreme don't script your
conversations but I kind of think about
you know this person might be a good
Ally for me and they might actually not
know what I'm doing so
um just just a small thing start
building that visibility I agree I
mean please go ahead no no go ahead
Robie in general I think that we all are
experts in many things with our lives
but if we're not sharing that expertise
with others then they don't know we're
experts in it and maybe you're not an
expert in the thing that you have a good
idea for but I bet you could become one
I bet you could do some research I bet
you could go to an event or a conference
or have a conversation or find an
article or take a course about it and
then you become an expert in what you
want to do and you just need to share it
you just need to get that
visibility and we all do things outside
our jobs that build up ibility you might
be working at your kids school uh you
might be doing voluntary activities all
those are super
helpful I agree I agree bring your life
into your job that's I think that's a
great take-home thanks Rita okay
abolutely next question Jonathan
Jonathan says hey I have three ideas
which one should I
prioritize O Okay Okay Okay
um so think about this like as a uh V
diagram in a sense so let's start okay
I'm going to do Dave Letterman style
here so start with number
three so think about you know is there
money a budget time you know resources
available for the
idea think about the audience so what's
that's number two uh what's important
for your boss or you know any audience
you are selling your idea to but the
number one and all all of these are
important but I would still say number
one is your passion it's it's really
about what you want to sell and it shows
if you're passionate about your idea
people really realize it's golden you
smile and and you can't stop talking
about it and they know you will follow
up and you will be there to see this
idea through it's it's almost like our
graduate students uh when they're
looking for their thesis topics they're
they're saying you know with I have
these three topics all of them sound
really good you know which one should I
pick and and
ultimately you know pick the one that
you're passionate about because people
will s see it you will care you will be
want to be promoting this idea and and
and doing in our case doing research
around it for a long time so you really
I would pick passion as number one but
don't forget that it also needs to be
top of mind and important for others um
and then there needs to be the budget
for it of
course I agree so it's the I love the
idea of the vend diagram because you can
see where the overlap is and and if you
lead with passion but also is there
interest in it is their budget in it or
other people going to think this is the
thing I think that that's a really good
road map because this isn't you know
selling your ideas within your
organization isn't a recipe it's more of
an art and you've managed to put a
framework around it too which is really
great so then you have lots of for it as
well and I want to also say something
congratulations you had three ideas or
or more lot of ideas which is great so
we all have good ideas we just sometimes
tend to think oh I don't have any ideas
but you have more ideas than you think I
agree and coming on the tail end of of
three ideas which one should I
prioritize I'm seeing a lot of questions
and a lot of comments from multiple
people probably seven different people
asking what if someone steals your idea
how do I know who to go to to talk about
my idea with and I I have some I have
some thoughts on this I'm sure you do as
well Rita about how to you know think
about this in terms of stealing ideas
would you know do you have some thoughts
on this for
us so let me put first my academic hat
on when I was very Junior in my
profession this was my number one worry
that somebody would steal my idea would
my my steal my great Des ation topic
because after all you devote
years and you do research and you get
the data and it takes a long time so I
would wake up in the morning I'm worried
that somebody else has published my idea
but turns out you know there a couple of
things first it's never the same idea if
if it's related you know it won't be the
same it's still your idea your passion
number two actually that's great news
because that's the community now you
have people who care about the same
things this is actually valuable so you
could maybe these these become your
Sidekicks maybe you do this together um
I I think people are too afraid of
stealing ideas we need more action
selling our ideas rather than worrying
that somebody else uh will steal them
but I'm with you I was there and I was
so worried because I felt it's my baby
and how can I get it out soon enough
before somebody else thinks about it the
other thing is that um people have lots
of ideas but who is going to actually
Implement that idea that really
matters I agree I agree Bob always says
Bob Sutton always says Innovation is
creativity plus implementation we all
can have a thousand ideas but who's
going to actually implement it if you're
going to be the person that implemented
that's your idea I mean it doesn't you
know you know take it as as I love I
love that reframe you gave of take it as
a compliment if someone wants to take
your idea that's a pretty good idea
bring them along bring them on board
strengthen numbers and you know have
those conversations with them I yeah I I
really love that for sure and I'll talk
to them you know say can we do this
together yeah yeah you wanna I always
think of it having a flotilla of support
for every idea that you bring forward
you know if I'm by myself but you know
and I also loved how you said evaluate
your allies what is your skill set what
is an ally skill set that you can
identify and how could it help move your
idea forward I think that's extremely
valuable thing to do when you're
thinking about it and something that we
often
forget yes because we're scared
someone's gonna take our
idea okay let's
see Andrea wants to know could you give
me another example of who I could tap as
an ally where can I
look so we talked about the uh the the
fellow
innovators and I'm often thinking about
people who have ideas and you know in
all hands uh they might you know post
ideas on
slack
and that's really your support group
that's the group in your organization
where you want to go and and you know
you want to hang out with them and you
want to that's a safe space for your
ideas to test your ideas so I I I would
really go to that group we also have you
know friends outside work so
uh another person in another
organization could be an Al in in in
interesting ways so so there are many
places to
look I agree and that's right in line
with a question here from Juliana she
says how can you test your own ideas
before you present them you've just
answered that so you could test them by
having conversations with people around
you with your Sidekicks and your allies
and then Juliana says are there any
go-to questions or themes you can think
through to make your idea bulletproof
bulletproof we all wish our ideas were
bulletproof right bulletproof or
stronger before you share it I think
it's just about Shoring it up to a
reasonable level what do you think about
that Rita in in response to Juliana's
question are there any questions themes
you can think through to make your idea
stronger before you share it oh
absolutely um so there are a couple I'm
thinking about the course and it's I
think it's it's really helpful here in
terms of just building your idea uh from
the ground up step by step and we we
talked about thinking about your
audience who are you selling to that
that's one of the most important things
to think about uh an idea can be
Bulletproof in one context but in
another organization it might you know
might not be urgent might not be top of
mind so it depends it totally depends it
depends on your idea it depends uh on
where to whom you are selling where you
are selling what's what's important in
the organization right now so I I I
would say there's a lot of homework for
you to do to figure out how to
bulletproof your idea but it starts with
thinking about you know who needs this
right now what's the who's the audience
and getting that feedback really getting
those reactions Robin Robin you always
have great ideas how do you bulletproof
your ideas yeah I think the first thing
is sometimes if we get so involved in
trying to bulletproof our idea we'll get
paralyzed in our in our timeline of what
we're doing with our idea sometimes it's
about yes get feedback but maybe when
you when you go to present your idea
you're rarely do we ever present present
an idea and you get like this flashing
green light of go go go what a great
idea a lot of times you get um
suggestions back that you'll pivot your
idea a little bit maybe you'll make some
changes make some suggestions I remember
um co-creating an idea with a colleague
of mine and we had a great idea that we
wanted to create this women's community
of having conversations and you know
it's called women rise we went on to
create it and we had a timeline that we
wanted to roll this out we went to
leadership we presented it and they said
well we think this is a great idea
however What If instead of the timeline
you're suggesting we did this and we did
this and we pivoted based on that and it
was better it was better for the amount
of work for functional teams so my
advice to to everyone and to Juliana who
asked this great question thanks so much
Juliana is yes you you want to get your
idea strong but don't get in you know
maybe avoid making it so bulletproof so
you never move it forward because you're
worried about it getting shot down it's
okay and you know feedback as you said
it's it's not a problem it's a gift it's
a gift to get feedback so thank you and
everybody has long carriers ahead of
them so this is you know if the first
doesn't work there's another chance
another opportunity and what I love by
the B about the course is we're talking
to real people with real ideas they want
to sell and they sold or or uh we trying
trying to get by and for so it's kind of
we have these individual case studies in
the course uh so we hearing from real
people so that that's so valuable about
this to me Rita catella thank you so
much for being here with us today
everyone out there thank you so much for
being here with us today we appreciate
it every comment every question every
Emoji you put across the screen thanks
so much and really appreciate it Rita
thank you again thank you so much this
was a lot of fun it was um signing off
from Stanford everyone thanks so much
bye-bye